hello and welcome to swipe coming to you
from the 2014 consumer electronics show
here in Las Vegas on this week's show
future fashions we take a look at some
of the wearable tech that's drawing in
the crowds pocket-lint Stewart miles
gives us his take on the big talking
point at this year's show TV takeovers
why how he chewed in is set change and
gaming glory we check out some of the
best releases that will get you going in
2014 well in case you don't know much
about siiii as it is the place where
once a year pretty much every big
technology brand comes to show the world
what they've been working on and one of
the big talking points this year is
wearable technology I've been talking to
someone with a interesting perspective
on it all now the headline here is all
about wearable and Bethany Simpson is
from I media connection in in Los
Angeles clearly a devotee first of all
what do you like about google glass well
I best mixed thoughts on google glass I
think it's very cool that it's very
techie I mean it's very insider when
else do you use augmented reality out in
the regular world I mean it gets a lot
of attention I've had a lot of people
coming up and asking what it is I
thought there'd be a lot more
recognition they'd say oh it's glass but
I think it's very early gen the
batteries and devices were a little bit
tough so I don't get a lot of battery
life out of class yet in fact they just
went dead a few minutes ago or else i'd
show you a little bit more of what they
could do they interfaced a little bit
hard to see it's a very small little of
pic window you guys might have tried it
on you might have tried it on this
little crystal right here is literally
where the display shows up and so it's
just a small little window and so I look
just above my visual eye and that's
where I can see a very light transparent
menu I think the act
interaction with Google glass is a
little bit rough at this point as well I
can check up to see what time it is what
the weather is what interesting things
are around me but I want more augmented
reality i wanted to tell me where is the
next event at so yes things like that
they say they're going to sell one and a
half million wearables this year do you
think the broader public wants this
could you see that there is a use for
the ordinary folk well I've heard of the
geek set myself and so you know a lot of
it friends in Los Angeles of course we
think it's really exciting thinking from
the normal consumer side i just spent
the holidays with my family and whatever
they think is interesting i think that's
sort of the bellwether I think it's
early I think people love to track their
fitness I think that they find it very
interesting to engage with their devices
but again I think it's still more of a
thing at this point it's more exciting
than it is actually usable I know I
heard the numbers are going to be a lot
more sales coming up this year than
there were last year but personally even
as an insider who really geeks out on
this stuff I think it's a little bit
early of course it's not all about
wearables and fall detector knows who
fly in from all around the world to be
here for a full-on week of reveals and
big announcements there's plenty to see
one man keeping across it all for us is
pocket-lint Stewart miles here's his
video diary Aram on days 0 of CES the
show hasn't even started have already
seen more wearable tech and I probably
most people have done in a lifetime it
was everything from a toothbrush they're
monitored and 3d sense to your mouth to
lots of wearable stuff to track your
fitness the track whether you're eating
right to try and watch like everything
this is being a show at wearables and
hasn't even started yet
so it's been the press day at CES today
and that's the chance for all the big
boys to start announcing all their
products we've seen major announcements
from LG Samsung and Sony stuff that's
grab my eye while I got to see a
flexible Oh LED 4k TV from LG that was
quite impressive it actually changes
shape of the press of a button and then
there was the pep com which was a chance
for the smaller companies once again to
show their wares there we saw everything
from a doorbell that was connected to
the internet so you could get a phone
call when someone's knocking on your
door and just a menagerie of more
wearables from everything's tracking
your fitness that is really the big
words this week wearable wearable
wearable so I just got back to my hotel
room after a busy first day at CES on
the show floor and it's been pretty
crazy I've seen some really interesting
things including the chance to sit in a
four and a half million dollar
Lamborghini to test a
fifty-thousand-dollar sound system from
Monster and when they turn the volume up
it made every bone in my body shake but
that wasn't the most bizarre thing I saw
today probably that award has to go to
Intel I saw two things they're in there
sort of innovation section one was a
computer the size of an SD card and the
second was a baby onesie that you could
connect to the internet to be able to
check your newborn child movement
breathing and temperature up for the end
of day 2 at CES and I've seen plenty I
managed to get to play with the new
oculus rift it's a virtual reality
headset or throws you into the game and
they've added a quite a new couple of
features still a prototype stage the
product hasn't launched yet but it's
looking very exciting the new features
include Santa called loca systems which
allows you to lean into the shot as well
as tracking your head move
now also managed to get to sit in a
dashboard of the Audi TT which is
launching later this year they've tried
to do as best they can to get her or
with dials and instead for all the sort
of virtual cockpit is echoing it in the
main dashboard area lino we have it now
changes from dials from speedometers to
mapping data to the entertainment and
everything else I think it's really
going to be the way that files we move
suddenly in the future and they're gonna
be a lot more interactive than just a
needle that twix so I decided you go
faster apart from that I've also seen a
bunch of robots everything from a window
bot that cleans your windows to a grill
bottom thrills that cleans your grill we
are in America after all CES 2014 is
coming to an end and heading off to the
airport see you later TV has been
another area that has got tech fans
talking as Katie Spencer reports
samsung's launch of its curved Ultra HD
TV has to be one of CES is biggest
headline makers but perhaps not for the
reasons originally intended your Tokyo
dying was too much for transformers
director Michael Bay to take so as he
awkwardly left the stage sent social
media into a frenzy for manufacturers
standing out in the crowded TV market
can be tricky one of this year's main
battlegrounds has been ultra
high-definition you are putting four
times the amount of pixels in the space
that you currently see so in a sense
high-definition today is two million
these sets produce eight million giving
you a sharper picture and also allows
you to sit closer to your TV and still
see a wonderful picture so you can go
larger in a smaller space the move
towards Ultra HD has been driven in part
by how popular video streaming has
become at this year's CES Netflix and
Amazon both announced plans to show more
of their TV shows and films in the
format the other exciting new innovation
was over screen shape right now you can
buy a curved TV but if you can't decide
if you want to be flat or not you can
choose with these flexible ones curved
is supposed to be a more immersive
experience when it surrounds you but why
settle for a curved screen when you
could have the image played straight
onto your eyes it's called a virtual
retinal display and how that's different
from other display technologies is that
there is no screen at all the image is
projected directly on your retina a step
too far well that's how many experts now
see 3d technology when it comes to
trying to tweak our telly watching
habits predicting what will catch on can
be tricky 3d required completely new
production it required a very different
type of production so you couldn't watch
just anything in 3d and it enforced a
new type of viewing behavior on the
consumer ultra high-definition is a true
extension of the
sisting way of watching TV a small step
rather than a giant leap Ultra HD
shouldn't feel like that big a departure
from what we're used to and because of
that many believe the change in quality
might just be enough to tempt more of us
into buying a new television Katie
Spencer sky news but CES isn't the only
tech story we've been talking about this
week back in the UK skies Neil Patterson
has a roundup of this week's tech news
many thanks Greg I'm honestly really so
happy for you being over there in Vegas
whilst I'm stuck here well any in the
battle of the games console Giants the
ps4 seems to be leading the way sony
says it's old 4.2 million consoles by
the end of last year and is on track to
sell 5 million by the end of March well
that's quite a way ahead of Microsoft's
Xbox one which at the last count had
only shifted 3 million units by the end
of 2013 however both makers look set to
benefit from the news that their
products can now be bought in China the
Chinese government has temporarily
lifted a ban on selling phone video
games consoles which obvious they opens
up a potentially huge marketplace china
band games consoles back in two thousand
there has been a bit of a tussle on
twitter over social media copyright the
debate centers around this tweet by a or
Scott who's a film critic in the United
States it ended up being published as a
full-page ad in The New York Times
what's more the tweet itself was edited
to this the critic and says his
permission was sought but he didn't give
consent inside llewyn davis is one of
this year's Oscar hopefuls which could
be why it was edited as the Academy
doesn't allow negative campaigning yahoo
has confirmed that its european site was
infected with malware designed to turn
PCs and to Bitcoin miners in a statement
it's admitted that for four days in
January the malware was fined present
and adds on its homepage it's not as
many as two million users couldn't be
infected experts believe with a view to
creating a huge network of mining
machines and speaking of Bitcoin the
developers of a new virtual currency
have run into a spot of bother with one
of the most well known rappers and
world who'd have guessed Kanye West
wouldn't be happy about developers
launching the crypto currency called
coin II well as well as a little cartoon
version of the rapper's face for its
logo the website also has a currency
mining program called gold digger his
lawyers have issued a cease and desist
letter accusing the site of copyright
infringement and trying to profit from
Yeezys public image well back now to
Greg in Sin City Las Vegas where I'm
assured he's having the worst time
possible a new year means new games to
get excited about and we've been
checking out a few in this week's games
review my first game for 2014 is metal
gear rising revengeance now metal gear
rising came out of the air at the
beginning of 2013 on xbox 360 and
playstation 3 and it was a moderate
success did really well with critics but
not a lot of people bought it there's
actually a really really good action
game the focus is on swordplay it takes
place in the Metal Gear universe which a
lot of gamers will really know
this PC Edition that's been released and
for 2014 it brings together the main
game all of the downloadable content
that came out on consoles and loads of
costumes for the main character of ridin
and because it's on PC and if you've got
a powerful enough PC it looks absolutely
beautiful way better than the
playstation 3 and xbox 360 versions it's
a relatively short experience it's a
traditional action game it's not really
going to change the world but if you're
into platinum games previous works or
you're a metal gear solid fan is pretty
much guaranteed to satisfy remote
piloting an AI wiping have been disabled
there have been literally tens of mario
party games released across a multitude
of nintendo platforms going across
gamecube and n64 and these games that
the idea behind them is that they're
board games for multiple players with
the difference being that when you roll
the dice and move certain number of
spaces you land on certain spaces that
will initiate a mini game that you play
with the other players in the game and
it's it's very much traditional board
game territory now the 3ds version it's
interesting because you buy one
cartridge and then you share the game
amongst your 3d sewing friends so if
you've got four players each with a 3ds
console you only need to buy one copy of
the game and then that game can be
shared wirelessly with friends which is
quite a novel concept I think because
when you need to buy that that single
copy of the game my main problem with it
is that it doesn't feel like it's a game
of skill it feels like it's a game of
chance it does have some some fun and
entertaining mini games that you can
play with your friends you just need to
make sure that your friends own3d
sponsors
don't starve was released on the PC last
year and it's a very interesting little
indie game that's very different to a
lot of other games on the market
essentially you're you find yourself in
this cartoon Tim Burton s world and
you're given no instructions but you
have to sort of forage for items and
basically protect yourself from the
monsters that come out at night if
you're used to your games holding your
hand this game really doesn't do any of
that just throws you straight into it so
for that reason it appeals to me as
someone who likes indie games who likes
games that doesn't do things that
haven't been done before but also bear
in mind that it can be quite difficult
so when it's an interesting game don't
starve is being released as a
downloadable title for PlayStation 4 but
it's also part of the PlayStation Plus
collection so it's free if you're a
PlayStation Plus subscribers so if that
happens to be yours no excuse for lunch
at me now the xbox one finds itself in a
similar position to the PlayStation 4
and as much as there's not many new
games coming out for it but I wanted to
pick up on one game that was released
just before Christmas which is really
fun and interesting it's called max the
curse of brotherhood and it's one of
those side-scrolling 2d platformers of
which there aren't very many at the
moment and the hubby in this particular
game is that Max has a magic marker that
he can use to draw items in the game so
you can draw himself a bridge or a water
fountain and you use that element draw
things using the control pad to solve
various puzzles and kill off enemies and
do various things in the game which is a
an interesting mechanic
is it downloadable title so it's
relatively cheap about 10 pounds in the
UK and there's a lot of game in there's
lots of worlds to explore it looks
beautiful I really like these side
scrolling platformers and like I said
there's not many many of them around and
Max is a is a charming little game
that's very very cheap side they're
thoroughly recommended well that's it
for this week remember you can catch up
with breaking tech stories all week on
Sky News for iPad our smartphone apps
and sky news com goodbye from Las Vegas
and we'll see you next time